Alejandro Marconi de 51 años Sufre de
cáncer de pulmón avanzado desde el año
pasado su día a día es luchar para
seguir viviendo en una ciudad con
índices altos de polución
Esperanza no hay acá en Sí en Bolivia no
no no hay los que estamos con enfermo
cáncer solamente luchamos para vivir un
poco más Aunque Alejandro fumaba
ocasionalmente El origen de su
enfermedad según los médicos podría ser
la contaminación ambiental el ambiente
que tenemos acá en La Paz está
contaminado entonces
con lo que estaba un poquito ya
delicado o algo puede ser uno de los
factores según ellos la contaminación
ambiental ha sido identificada como una
de las mayores causas del cáncer de
pulmón en Bolivia según un estudio de
2.160 casos realizado por los neumólogos
del instituto Nacional del tórax dejando
atrás al tabaquismo como la razón
principal tenemos por lo menos un 60% de
casos en gente que jamás ha fumado
tampoco tiene en su entorno ningún
fumador y que desarrolla cáncer de
pulmón la conclusión ha causado una
alerta porque el país ha vivido picos de
contaminación ambiental debido a las
quemas agrícolas el meteorólogo Luis
blaked ha advertido que en términos
proporcionales los incendios en Bolivia
son los peores de la región como han
mostrado los mapas de la NASA
contaminamos más que nuestros vecinos
como Brasil como Argentina esto es esto
es alarmante según los neumólogos las
consecuencias de respirar aire
contaminado y contraer cáncer no son
visibles de forma inmediata y pueden
darse en un plazo de cinco a diez años a
los bolivianos solo les queda volver a
los tapabocas cuando la polución Se
dispara